dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly say it start
transferring a mazing area in machine
learning and AI research where we take
two images image number one is an input
photograph and image number two is the
desired style and the output of this
process is the content of image number
one with a style of image number two
this first paper opened up an incredible
new area of research as a result a ton
of different variants have emerged in
the last two years feed-forward style
transfer for close to real-time results
temporally coherent style transfer for
videos and much much more and this one
not only outperforms previously existing
techniques but also broadens the horizon
of possible star transfer applications
and obviously a human would be best at
doing this because a human has an
understanding of the objects seen in
these images and now hold on to your
papers because the main objective of
this method is to create semantically
meaningful results for star transfer it
is meant to do well with input image
pairs that may look completely different
visually but have some semantic
components that are similar for instance
a photograph of a human face and the
drawing of a virtual character is an
excellent example of that in this case
this learning algorithm recognizes that
they both have noses and uses this
valuable information in the star
transfer process and the result it has
three super cool applications first the
regular photo to star transfer that we
all know and love
second it is also capable of swapping
the style of two input images
third and hold on to your papers because
this is going to be even more insane
style or sketch to photo
and we have a plus one here as well so
forth
it also supports color transfer between
photographs which will allow creating
amazing time-lapse videos I always try
to lure you fellow scholars into looking
at these papers so make sure to have a
look at the paper for some more results
on this and you can see here that this
method was compared to several other
techniques for instance you can see the
cycle consistency paper and patch match
and this is one of those moments when I
get super happy because more than 170
episodes into the series we can not only
appreciate the quality of these new
results but we also had previous
episodes about both of these algorithms
as always the links are available in the
video description make sure to have a
look it's going to be a lot of fun the
source code of this project is also
available we also have a ton of episodes
on computer graphics in this series make
sure to have a look at those as well
every now and then I get emails from
viewers who say that they came for the
AI videos in just in case watched a
recent episode on computer graphics and
were completely hooked give it a try
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
you